Today we're going to talk about uh
decentralization in Marc and DeFi. Uh
this is for me a very interesting topic
because
um it's what's not included in the
regulation.
However, DeFi projects should really
really look into the concepts of
decentralization that are in the law. So
with us we have two panelists who in
their own experience have been going
through the journey of decentralization.
So first of all I'd like you to
introduce yourselves a little Greg.
>> Uh Greg J founder CEO of QPQ AAG. Um
I've been in this journey on this
journey now for 23 years uh trying to to
achieve what I refer to as the intel of
economics which is the restitution to
the individual and the communities in
which they reside
both their data and their economic
capacity. Um, and that sounds very grand
and very very difficult and it has been,
you know, 23 years. I started off
spending a lot of my own money trying to
build a system that united all of the
major markets around the world into a
single system. And ultimately the
problem with that system was it was
massively centralized. So in order to
get the major actors to work with it,
they they just wouldn't because you've
got this massive single point of failure
and no matter how well regulated or
covered you are, how much capital you
have, ultimately that's a massive
concentration of power. So I sheld what
I was doing in 2009 believing that a
technology would come that would open
the door. And I saw those things emerge
with various distributed ledger
technologies. And I made the erroneous
assumption that given that they were
getting hundreds of millions of dollars,
they were going to actually build a
blockchain that worked. But nobody did.
So I focused my time on how we might get
to a state of being able to uh and the
team that I assembled in terms of how we
might actually be able to to bring whole
assets onchain completely to the
satisfaction of any regulator and also
restore data to the individual but
understand that those individuals don't
exist as islands. They exist within a
context of a wider world with big data
sets against which we make a lot of our
decisions. Um unfortunately nobody did
solve the blockchain problem. So I was
very lucky to unite with a team who had
some fantastic ideas and also a base to
build upon that allowed us to do that.
So today
QPQ is is sort of a a container with a
whole variety of things to come. But the
beginning is the gajimar as we call it
which is an actual blockchain that
actually works instantiating a
cryptocurrency put that puts the
currency back into crypto.
>> Right. Excellent. Excellent. Um I think
one of the the main topics and the
reasons why we're here uh it's for uh in
MCAR we have recital 22 and uh in the
recital 22 basically what it's
mentioning is that if the a crypto asset
service provider um is fully
decentralized they do not fall under the
MCAR regulation.
Uh the difference between a recital and
an article is that the article is
actually in the law and the recital is
actually the spirit of the law. And we
were discussing a little bit outside
about what what a big difference this is
in terms how the European Union uh
creates legislation in in that having
adding this recital to interpret what is
the spirit of the law. If
you are a decentralized project, a DeFi
project, it's going to be very difficult
for you to navigate uh all of these
thousands of pages and and really
concepts in terms of decentralization
decentralization.
So the first
uh question that I have for you is
sufficient decentralization.
Okay. What is in your opinion and maybe
Martin you can start in the context of
of governance what what for you is
sufficient decentralization
under mcart
>> for me it's really simple the entire
purpose of blockchain is to be able to
trust the message not the messenger
securely at scale those are your tests
if you can't actually trust the message
you have to in some way, shape or form,
trust an intermediary, then in that case
you are requiring trust. And if you are
requiring trust, then you must have
oversight. And that oversight typically
occurs in the context of having
regulatory oversight, which means that
they're subject to auditing and so on.
So we look at all of the layer 2s as
they like to call themselves who are
really payment service providers without
the grace of being regulated as such and
you can see that they're highly
centralized operations in order to
pretend that a square wheel is not
square Ethereum. Um,
if you start at that point, then I think
you you have to appreciate that
instantaneous decentralization simply
doesn't happen unless you smash
something.
You have to have a progression toward
that state.
But ultimately, the intent is very
important in that that it's not such a
problem that something is decentralized.
It's when it tries to pretend that it's
decentralized that's a really big
problem. And that's nearly a cancer
eating out this entire industry because
it's extraordinarily difficult from
somebody who's not technically grounded
in it to be able to analyze something
and really draw out the realities of
where the points of control are. And of
course, the irony of the whole thing in
this point is that one of the best
speeches ever about centralization and
power was by Tony Ben when questioning
the European Union in the ascension of
the United Kingdom. And it was the five
questions to power. And I can't remember
them precisely, but it was what power do
you have?
How do you use it? To what ends? Who
gave you that power? And how do we take
it back?
And
so where you see a centralization, you
nearly need to apply those questions to
it and ask the question, well, if we
can't take it back, for example, you
know, if we can't depose you, then
actually your power is absolute. And so
it goes on. So it's it's a continuum
along all of those points that people
need to evaluate. And I think it's very
tough for an outsider to do because of
the the dense technical writing that
tends to come with these things and in
some cases works of literary fiction and
art that should be preserved for
humanity as examples of quite immense
works of pros.
But that doesn't help people.
>> Yeah. One of the things that that I've
been working a lot with is that
decentralization
is not a point in time, it's a process.
Uh and it's an evolution. So I think
this really has to be considered because
you have stages of decentralization
according to the advancement of the
different projects and this should be
considered in the regulation. as I say
nothing is tr was started truly
decentralized not even the big bang you
know the universe was not you know
decentralized at one point it was a
centralized point and then it became
decentralized um so I think it's very
important uh for us to consider that
evolution so I would like to just for
the clarity and for people to understand
a little bit what it takes for a company
to
through a decentralization process and
the reason why each of one you uh have
decided to do that is important.
>> QPQ is a centralized entity. I'm a
majority shareholder of the company. So,
it's clearly centralized. But the
Gajimaru is the blockchain that we have
built to go out into that. And we reject
the entire layer 2, layer 0, layer 1
narrative because really layer 2 and
layer zero are attempting to predate
upon the credibility of a blockchain
protocol by pretending to be associated
with them. Layer 2s are centralizations
in order to expedite flow. Layer zero is
a company who wishes to be a central
counterparty to every transaction and
should therefore be the most regulated
entity in the entire market. But they're
not. So what we intend to go with
instead is the idea of Ripper resource
infrastructure platform application. And
if you look at the blockchain firmament,
there's a lot of infrastructure. There's
plenty of platforms and there's a few
applications that aren't simply fraud.
Um,
what's missing is that resource layer.
Now, if you're going to put a resource
layer into the world as we intend, you
really cannot have any governance
whatsoever because you're really putting
yourself in a position of total
centralization of power. And that is
something that no amount of saying how
good I am is ever going to change. You
cannot trust me. you can never ever even
if I were the Lord Jesus Christ himself,
you cannot give me the keys to that
kingdom. So we actually went the
opposite direction from this. We decided
right from the outset that there would
be once we got through test net and
whitelist mining there would be no
governance of any kind at the resource
layer. Now the object of the resource
layer is to enable all of the
infrastructure to connect. So if you
think it through that's exactly what you
want. You want an open trust market in
which people can operate transparently
and fairly. And for that reason, it has
to be proof of work. I should explain
that a little bit.
>> The big problem, proof of work
essentially allows for an open and fair
competition for who is going to be the
leader and write out what happens on the
chain next. And each time somebody new
is elected and it's elected through a
completely transparent process.
when you see what's happening with most
of the blockchains, they they work in a
in a anonymous proof of stake. So, put
your hand up if you work in a company
where you'd be comfortable with the
board voting and you not knowing who
voted for what. You wouldn't, but that's
actually what you're supporting whenever
you use a blockchain that uses uh
anonymous proof of stake. It's
ridiculous when you start to unpack it.
So, we went down the proofof work route
for this, which means you have an open
competition. It's Bitcoin next
generation quite literally implemented
and it means that you can trust because
there is no intermediary. It is
completely decentralized. We've actually
gone one step further because there is
this question of well what happens when
professional miners step in? Well,
you're going to have maybe 10 20 of them
who control the market or in the case of
Bitcoin 3. Um actually we thought we
could use whitelist mining to try and
bring a 100,000 people from Zorg Schvitz
Likenstein Nealden our home spots as it
were and actually get them mining
because we we implemented the cuckoo
cycle that allows it to be done with
CPUs and memory function instead. And
it's not a perfect answer, but we're
trying to use the period in which we
have some control to broaden the access
and and acceptance of that control to
everybody else before it becomes
something that's open. And I think
that's as much as we can do to ensure
the decentralization. But the the key
point is there must be no single one
ring to rule them all type thing in
this. That is what we call the Garden of
Eden problem. And to date, every other
blockchain has bitten the apple and that
apple is the temptation to become the
blockchain itself. Your business model
is being the blockchain.
>> I I think that's actually a a very
interesting Could you briefly explain
the Garden of Eden Eden? Then
>> it's as simple as that. It's that the
temptation is that we could build this
amazing thing that could emancipate the
world and create an infinitely larger
economy than the one we have because
everybody can participate fairly and
transparently. Or we can own the chain
and we can run it, which they've all
done. All of them in one way or another
have all bitten this apple. You know,
people criticize Salana because they're
honest about having bitten the apple.
They've all done it. Um
and in doing that they suddenly cast
themselves out of the garden of Eden.
And the garden of Eden in this context
is providing an infrastructure sorry a
resource layer upon which everything can
be built that nobody owns nobody
controls. And I understand why because
it's very difficult. We talk to funders
and we say you know we've spent 60
million to get to this point and by the
way we're going to make the whole thing
free and open to everybody. That's a
hard cell, right?
>> But what you have to believe in is that
capitalism is not about I win, you lose.
Capitalism is about I win, you win, we
win. And it's about creating a bigger
pie for all. And in doing that, we will
profit extraordinarily well with the
other businesses that we want to roll
out onto an actual blockchain that
actually works, which right now doesn't
exist. And when you think of the
hundreds of millions that have sunk into
these projects, you you know, as as one
of my co co-founding team says, where's
the project to to um colonize Mars?
Because they've done nothing else.
They've spent an awful lot of money on
on getting some of the most magnificent
marketing and some of the best pros
writing this side of Shakespeare, but
they haven't actually delivered any real
innovation.
>> Yeah. I I I I think I mean for me that's
why this concept of decentralization or
this journey of decentralization is so
fascinating uh because
there's not a formula that two
organizations
will have the same journey to
decentralization
but we do have to uh find a way to
provide regulators with a measure to be
able to describe
that sufficient decentralization because
it's going to be very complex. So in
that context, how can we provide
regulators to be able to describe that
measure of decentralization?
I think the interesting thing is that
what you pointed out at the very start
was something very uneuropean
commission-like because for the most
part the EU exists to create new jobs
and compliance and that way sustain the
economy. Um but in that specific context
they open the door to the spirit of the
rules and the spirit of the rules opens
the door to intelligent analysis.
That dialogue between adult and adult
and I think something we touched on this
in the chat earlier something like a
rating an independent rating agency that
was actually able to look at a series of
measurable context but also look at
other aspects to that have wider
conversations. as we say that there's
all these rating agencies like standard
and pause and most of the information
that they sumate and provide to you is
actually publicly available. What you're
really paying them for is the
intelligence of their analysis on top
and a rating agency that understood
decentralization understood how to
impose those measures but also
understand the intent and purpose and
the spirit of what was being worked on
from the other side would actually be
extremely useful for their purposes. And
when you look at the wide affirmment of
what we described with Micah and I think
was very intelligently exposed this
morning was that the regulation started
off being quite succinct and clever and
the more the committee got bigger the
bigger the regulation got the more
unwieldy it became and the more useless
it became excuse me um the more
difficult to manage it became
>> which in many aspects is true
>> but I think this would be an opportunity
point where actually you could bring
intelligence back into the process and
instead of having a highly fractured
market where every regulator is looking
at this differently, an independent
rating agency could give it some
real flexibility but also teeth. I'd
also say this, you know, very often we
talk about the relationship being from
the person potentially seeking
regulation. I mean we will there are
there are value additive services that
we intend to provide to to people who
use the gashimaru and indeed any other
chain and we will set those up in
Switzerland and and in Lichenstein. Um
but why is that why is that dynamic only
one way? Because actually if regulators
were to come and talk to the team at
QPQ, we've some of the most experienced
people anywhere in the world in this
industry and we've got papers written on
all of these things internally. Come and
ask us what we think and you know ask us
we we don't mind telling you the truth.
Is that centralization? Yes. Why?
Because of X. Because you know I had a
very interesting moment about four
months ago. A friend of mine sent me a
paper from a certain blockchain
and asked me to evaluate it for him. And
I sent it back covered in red ink and
very furious comments because no, I take
this very personally because I've been
doing this for 23 years. This has been
my life work. My blood, sweat, and tears
have gone into this. Every penny I've
ever had has gone into this. I want to
see this done and done well and I'm
passionate about it. So I wrote I sent
it back and I said, "How on earth does
nobody see that that's total
centralization without any sign of a
blockchain anywhere within the entire
thing in any form, shape, shape, or form
being described?" And he wrote back and
said, "Greg, you're probably one of 10
people in the world who could make that
assessment in that time frame."
That's the problem. So why is that the
problem? Why? because I'd be very open
to someone coming into me at the SEC if
they like come in and ask me is that
centralization yes or no why X learn
from us don't just put it on us to come
to you come and talk to us we want to
engage with you we want to see this work
I'm sick and tired of having to listen
to children in this industry I'm sick
and tired of being told that we need
sandboxes no you don't sandboxes are for
children you need to play by the rules
and you need to treat adults you need to
treat regulators like adults and be
treated like adults because you earned
the right to be. That's how we need to
build.
>> I I I totally agree and uh and actually
uh that was one of the reasons why I
fell in love with Likenstein.
>> Yeah.
>> Is because here you can actually sit
down with a regulator and explain your
ideas and they'll give you the thumbs
up, thumbs down and you can actually
work through the whole process. Uh, and
I think that's one of the unique things
that we have in in Leerstein in terms of
regulation.
>> It is.
>> So, they're already kicking us out. I
told you this was going to go really
quickly. Um, thank you very much. It's
fascinating both of your stories. Uh,
and if anybody wants to talk to them
after after we get off stage, uh,
they're they're going to be available.
Let's get up for Pablo Martin and
Gregory.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks, Greg.